two of the rules of procedure
on a proposal from the president and
with the agreement of the political
groups I'd like to inform the house that
the vote on the ACT in support of
ammunition production will be held on
Thursday the 13th of July
the deadlines will be the following
amendments
need to be tabled by today the 11th of
July at 1pm split and separate votes
will have to be put in by
7 pm today
so I've opened the sitting the first
item on the agenda is the report by Mr
luina
on nature restoration
and I'd like to give the floor
to the reporter for his presentation
this year
the fly is yours
thank you
it's enough audience for me thank you
president commissioner
foreign
I think the time has come to have a
tranquil debate on nature and I'm going
to have one last stab at convincing you
please be reasonable for three reasons
firstly for the future
the law says that we need to restore bio
uh ecosystems and habitats because 95 of
habitats are in a poor situation 48 of
crops depend on colonization by insects
insects are disappearing 70 of soil is
degraded which puts production of food
in danger and makes ecosystems more
vulnerable to extreme climate events for
the last 40 years Europe has been
warming at twice the global rate
well-being of people improves the more
green areas there are reducing pollution
and reducing the danger of zoonotic
disease I didn't make that up
we didn't make that up this comes from
IP best the intergovernmental platform
on biodiversity and ecosystem Services
comes from the soils Observatory and the
latest Copernicus climate report it's
science the law is good for all but
particularly
farmers
Fishers
and everyone else who is actively hit
involved in working alongside ecosystems
the green deal will only be possible if
we have a nature restoration law to go
with it
the parliament's role is also important
which brings me on to my next point
we've been building Europe for 70 years
now and we do not yet have legislation
which directly applies to Nature
so the European Parliament today and
tomorrow should not go down in history
as having been
a blocking agent so I say to the Epp
bits in on the ground but I say to those
of you who are here that we do need this
law to go through to get rid of that
veto so that we can hold the discussions
which we need to hold and
the next point
for the sake of History
Mr Weber perhaps held up in traffic took
a
dangerous Journey from uh touring into
zonnenberg I call you not to do away
with the Cordon sanitar do not go
further reactionary embrace
this proposal
is defended by
and presented by Ursula Von delein name
may ring a few bells and in Council
countries like Bulgaria Czech Republic
Croatia Greece Island Romania Lithuania
ring any bells those countries they've
got the Epp family in power in those
countries so
we've had lots of fake news
about this law I'll just pick on one
that it will put food security at risk
in Europe look at the science look at
the facts it's quite the opposite we
actually need fertile soil and
pollenisers in order to achieve food
security
thank you all for all of the work which
has gone into this Rodriguez
the three of you who've put in so much
effort on working on this law I'd also
like to
tell you something which has not been in
the public domain the Epp was
negotiating a lot of these compromises
had Epp support and then Mr Weber said
no we pull out so thanks to all of those
who were working in the meantime and I'd
like to thank all of the S D team it
would not have been possible to come so
far without you and those who are
outside ngos scientists the associations
of environmentalists and others I don't
have much time so leave it there thank
you president what we're calling on you
those of us as groups or individuals who
support this will support it but others
please give it a chance because
otherwise Parliament will go down in
history as being an obstacle to a law on
nature so for the future for the sake of
the role of this Parliament and for the
sake of History virgin failure comment
uh
moving on to the representative of the
commission on agriculture and rural
development Miss Allen Sunday
thank you very much president
commissioner ladies and gentlemen
protecting ecosystems and restoring them
is a necessity that we share
wholeheartedly but restoring nature
cannot mean a stop of all handicraft
production
forestry or agriculture production
not producing sorry no producing is not
a bad word
what we're seeing on the table well
despite the Health crisis despite the
geopolitical situation
the commission
and part of this chamber is not actually
taking into account reality in the world
ten percent of our agricultural
territory is is something they're
claiming is not risking our food
security but food production from
agriculture is not gonna
pursue into this law allow us to be the
best in the world at producing we might
maybe we might be able to reduce uh
pesticide use here but the rest of the
world is still going to need to be fed
we're still gonna also have to import
food from the four corners of the world
where the standards are a long way from
ours and the environmental is the
environmental impact of this will be
negligible so yes Mr vice president Mr
Timmerman's withdraw this proposal
go back to the drawing board come back
with a pragmatic approach that will
actually help defend nature and restore
it
moving on to the representative of the
committee on Fisheries Miss karolina
Rose
Mr President commissioner for years
scientists have been warning of the
dangers to Nature we're already seeing a
very serious consequences not least for
Fishers marine ecosystems are
deteriorating
it is important to take
the appropriate measures in each
situation the Epp has been spreading
fake news on this subject they said the
nature restoration law was going to
create famine in Europe the experts said
no we need bees we need
marine ecosystems in good condition
without nature there is no food
you've been saying on social media that
the nature restoration law is
going to
destroy our land
I do hope that uh people in the Epp and
renewal think of the image of this house
and also the fate of farmers and Fishers
across Europe thank you
moving on now to the representative of
the European Commission
commissioner thank you Richards you have
the floor
president
state Secretary
honorable members
first of all I'm truly grateful for the
opportunity to address you today
on the crucial role that nature plays
for our future
and let me start by thanking reporter Mr
Luana all Shadow reporters and the
reporters of the two opinion giving
committees Miss sander
and Miss Ruth
and the many of you who I met over the
last year and even more so in recent
weeks to discuss the commission proposal
for nature restoration that we've
presented in June 2022
and I hope that these discussions have
led to a better understanding or even
convergence of each other's positions
because that's what decision making in
the EU is all about
this law is nothing less than the
flagship initiative of the European
green deal
nature and biodiversity pillar and it's
intrinsically linked to its climate
pillar
it's the first EU legal proposal on
nature since 30 years it is the eu's
climate law for biodiversity and the
success of one depends
the success on the other during the last
year the commission has worked very
closely with all actors involved and we
have listened very carefully to the full
range of issues that have been raised
and to your concerns several of you made
it clear that additional flexibility was
needed
in particular on some of the provisions
that may not have been clear enough and
thus were considered as potentially
hampering economic activities and many
member states have raised similar issues
we acknowledge that and we have
consequently showed openness to revisit
and improve certain provisions and to
enhance Clarity making sure the proposal
reflects the current reality
on that basis we have outlined possible
ways forward in the non-paper which we
submitted to you and to the Council on
the 8th of June we very much welcome the
positive response of the member states
to our recent non-paper and the fact
that Council took responsibility
engage constructively and agreed on
General approach on 20th of June and I
understand that the Spanish presidency
now stands ready to engage in trial of
negotiations provided of course that the
European Parliament adopts its mandate
honorable members
in the past weeks we have seen an
intense debate on our proposal because
the questions they are complex because
these issues are crucial for our
Collective future and because the stakes
are high
proof of this is the unprecedented
mobilization for this law from citizens
and in particular the youth with around
1 million signatures collected in
support the law
from hundreds of businesses in renewable
energy food and other sectors including
some of Europe's biggest corporations
from Farmers and Foresters concerned
about the impacts of biodiversity on
their land and production from over 6
000 scientists from Civil Society
organizations across the EU as well as
from International organizations such as
iucn and the unap that debate showed
very clearly that there is very broad
consensus that we need to restore nature
and that we can constructively discuss
and find Solutions on how
the consequences of the climate and
biodiversity crisis are becoming
increasingly visible also here in the
European Union
they already affect nearly every citizen
and every sector of the economy and they
are among the biggest threats to the
long-term resilience of Europe's food
security
in order to ensure the long-term food
security and resilience of our farmlands
forests
our seas we must improve their
biodiversity conditions and some of
these ecosystems are already severely
threatened by the growing impacts of
climate change in almost all parts of
Europe with droughts fires degraded
soils that risk food production and
livelihoods especially in the rural
areas
science is Crystal Clear far too much of
Europe Nature has now been degraded or
destroyed so it's vital to reverse that
Trend and time is running out some 80 of
you habitat types are now in bad or poor
condition
half of the global GDP depends on Niche
and 75 of our crops depends on
pollination
European Central Bank found that 72
percent of the Euro area firms about 3
million
are highly exposed to Nature related
services such as Timber clean water
pollination sand or healthy soils and
depended on at least one of them
sometimes more
75 percent of bank loans are to firms
that depend on ecosystem services so
financial institutions are clearly
exposed as well
the unsustainable use of Natural
Resources already costs thousands of
lives and billions of Euros between 1980
2021 weather and climate related damages
amounted to an estimated 560 billion
euros and the severe droughts experience
in the EU in August last year led to
losses in agricultural production
average between 5 and 10 for crops like
grain Maize sunflower and soybeans
droughts floods and forest fires have
become part of New Reality
while they are driven by climate change
the degradation of ecosystems and their
weakened resilience due to biodiversity
loss accelerates and intensifies the
impacts of these events
these are figures
but even more important are the people
behind these figures
reversing the strength by restoring
degraded nature must therefore be our
shared responsibility
honorable members it's my sincere hope
that the openness showed by the
commission with the known people that
the council's general approach as well
as the proposal presented last week by
the commission to complete the nature
pillar of the European green deal that
all these elements can facilitate
today's discussion that they reassure
those who felt that the commission
initial position was too far-reaching
and they remain still convinced to those
who would have expected even higher
ambition for the nature restoration
the green deal is highly pragmatic
approach to solving the climate and
biodiversity crisis
climate Solutions without nature
Solutions are half measures
let me give you a couple examples making
soils healthy it's not good just for
Farmers Foresters and habitats it's also
essential for ensuring the soils can
store carbon carbon-rich soils in turn
store water and mitigate the
consequences of flash storms
dead soils do none of that
boosting Innovation new business models
like carbon farming and promote
technological developments such as for
new genomic techniques are key parts of
commission's nature package all
proposals are interlinked and actually
strengthen each other they all
contribute and assist to achieve the
goals of the other proposals on the
table with nature restoration law in the
center
the move we do on nature
the more we do on nature the less stuff
we will have to be on climate action
nature is our best Ally infighting
climate change and if we don't take
proper measures to let it Thrive we will
be ditching our best chance to achieve
climate neutrality
honorable members
citizens
businesses scientists Farmers Foresters
cities our International Partners they
all expect us to act to address the
climate related challenges they face
which are aggravated by bad and
deteriorating state of our natural
ecosystems this very parliament in June
called for a strong nature restoration
law including binding targets and
together with the council the Parliament
and commission side and declaration only
six months ago on 22nd of December 2022
confirming that nature restoration was a
joint priority for 2023
today I am reconfirming to this house
that commission remains 100 committed to
turn this proposal into law
to showing the necessary flexibility and
to supporting the call legislators in
their search for compromise the council
has already engaged in this process and
I'm convinced that with a constructive
approach a compromise is possible also
within this house
in order to uphold the European Union's
International commitments under both
Paris agreement and the coming Montreal
biodiversity framework to ensure a
transition to sustainable economy and
deliver on the EU climate law and adapt
to climate change we need to urgently
restore and strengthen the resilience of
natural ecosystems across the U
and I know that many of you share this
urgency
either for trust
that you will seize this opportunity and
take responsibility to engage
constructively so that tomorrow this
house can adopt a mandate for trial of
negotiations with would also allow us to
reach a final agreement on the proposal
in time for cop 28 and the next
biodiversity cop 16. and to see the
entry into force of the nature
restoration law before the end of this
political term
dear colleagues this is not about
restoring nature for the sake of nature
it's about ensuring a habitable
environment where the well-being of
current and future Generations is
ensured where the land and seas continue
having the capacity to provide us the
goods and services that our lives our
economy fully depend on
it is about our lives it's about us and
those who come after us thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much
moving on now to speakers on behalf of
the groups I'll start with Miss
Christina Schneider
happy
president
on these false accusations I like to
clarify this so we as the Epp stand by
the objectives of the green European
green deal we want the Montreal
biodiversity protocol to apply across
the world but we don't agree on the path
to take they're very different ideas
about how to reach this the proposal
from the commission is going in the
wrong direction
protecting biodiversity can only go hand
in hand with the population
not by
voicing rules on the Foresters the
farmers Etc making them responsible for
the
disappearance of biodiversity nor by
removing arable Farmland from production
and endangering food production
nor
pitting
the environment against agricultural
production to date the commission hasn't
come up with full and complete data on
what this would involve even though
we've heard promises nor on financing
measures nor the ramifications on the
member states this remains a question
mark it's completely unclear how the
nature narration law would work in sync
with the existing 23
regulations that are already in force
but already meant to protect our
environment you might get the impression
that the commission has taken the wrong
path and gone awry
a poorly present put together a proposal
has meant that the commission's wasted
valuable time you don't get support by
trying to exert pressure on individual
members of parliament
through this Behavior vice president
timmermans has split this Parliament
three committees have taken the proposal
from the commission and rejected it and
tomorrow it will nevertheless come to
down to the wire in a vote in Parliament
hence to conclude let me underscore once
again we as the Epp stand by the green
deal but this proposed law is poorly
drafted and it is our duty as members of
parliament to call this out and we
intend to vote against we haven't
changed our demand come up with a new
better proposal
Take A New Path that will enjoy a
broad-ranging majority thank you
[Applause]
I'd now like to give the floor to the
chair of the group of the progressive
Alliance and socialists and Democrats
thank you president Environmental
Protection is going through a crucial
moment now in the EU this attempt led by
the Epp to reject the nature restoration
bill is sending out a terrifying message
about the
feasibility of the green deal
what the right has done is to see the
environment as being a key area for it
to take on the far right Mr Weber didn't
even have the decency to be here in the
chamber and show his face but I'm going
to use this Podium nonetheless to send
him a message
Mr Weber
Mr Vega your
grubbing for votes in a fake defense of
farmers and Rural environments
you've used a strategy of Lies denying
scientific facts and rubbing shoulders
with deniers
but it's
not only about climate change denial
we've seen a record high average
temperatures
000 people dying from high temperatures
in 2022 in Europe a million species now
endangered over 80 percent of habitats
are in a poor state
and although 3500 scientists and large
companies support this the Epp has
decided to declare war on nature
restoration on this law which is vital
in order to repair damage vital to
ensuring food security
necessary to ensure that businesses can
operate essential in order to combat the
ever more severe impact of climate
change in short a law which is vital to
ensuring that the planet will be
inhabitable by the people of today and
tomorrow
Mr Weber
is flying in the face of conservative
governments who supported this idea in
Council
but he's not only taking on his own
comrades but he's losing historical
memory the far-right in Hungary Poland
Italy Finland Spain
have a reactionary program
and the Epp is moving closer to Vox
attacking lgbtqi attacking women that
now attacking attempts to combat climate
change the Epp the The People's Party
and rocks are deniers
rubbing
future generations of their future
the people of the future Europeans of
the future deserve a decent green deal
without sacrificing what has been
achieved socially Europe that protects
that progresses that moves forward
that's what we want someone to move
backwards
they want hate they want destruction but
social Democrats are clear about what
our destiny is less inequality more
rights
move forward or backwards which is it to
be for us is very clear forwards
thank you very much
now on behalf of the renew Europe group
the chair of the group Mr Stefan says
Johnny
thank you president colleagues so here
we are after weeks of debate and
one-upmanship we're called upon to vote
on the nature restoration Act
personally
I believe in an ambitious law my group
believes in a text that can bring
together all those who care about the
environment
all those who've supported the green
deal from the outset but
face it the debate has got out of hand
both in form and content it's gone awry
it's
a huge mess
and we know who will be to blame if the
text is rejected
on the one hand a European commissioner
Mr Timmerman's of fortunately not uh
here adamant in the media but someone
needs to explain to me how you build a
majority from inside your office in
Brussels
in terms of the strategy in relation to
this law there's a whole series of other
political texts that the commission has
presented on the green deal there's been
so much fake news about this proposed
legislation how many misunderstandings
would we have avoided if the commission
had had an overall strategy on the green
deal text and on the other hand as
earlier speakers have said the
conservative group happy to show that an
alliance between the right and climate
Skeptics is possible the reality Mr
Weber is
but you don't want this text
whatever the amendments
perhaps purely for
parties and political reasons now it's
37 degrees today in Strasbourg I can
assure you that those of you in the Epp
that your partisan objectives will not
be audible to Future generations to our
children so we have a lack of strategy
from the commission on one hand partisan
political one-upman on the other
that's where the responsibility lies for
the current situation at present the
text is in danger of being rejected my
group is still painfully trying to do
the impossible we've proposed amendments
all is not lost we have 24 hours nature
and biodiversity deserve this effort
the Parliamentary group
has been trying to show Unity internally
I've been working for that and for the
European Parliament more generally now
let's not create any more precedence
that
green deal has worked thanks to bridging
our divides we have bridged our divides
but some europes are in the process of
creating new ones
to mean nature and biodiversity have no
political colors really me it is a
short-term strategy they are following
only the extremes will benefit from this
parliamentary polarization ladies and
gentlemen we will do our work
in the next 24 hours we will be
proposing a strategy to achieve a
majority and to avoid rejection of the
text
I call on all those who have political
responsibilities those who work together
with the committee chairs with the
record chairs and the shadow repertoires
all those who've worked on this strategy
please let us work together to ensure
that this text can get through I call on
everyone from right to left to shoulder
their responsibilities let us ensure
victory for this text thank you
thank you the next speaker is the
co-chair of the green group Terry Rankin
colleagues our our rivers are dying our
forests are sick our nature is in deep
crisis we have to restore our nature not
in a distant future not when Epp has
gotten their act together we have to act
now for preserving nature the basis of
our agriculture the basis of our
economic prosperity for keeping the
climate targets because 10 percent out
of the 55 percent that we have agreed to
reduce our emissions by 2030 a
nature-based climate action for keeping
our competitiveness to the self-declared
business groups in this Parliament you
heard the appeal by major companies like
Unilever or Ikea to let the nature
restoration law pass so dear Epp
colleagues many of your parties are
actually based on Christian values
centered on the preservation of creation
please follow your inner conviction and
not what your group leader is telling
you and vote tomorrow in favor of the
nature restoration law dearly new
colleagues the nature restoration law is
about Freedom the destruction of
biodiversity already today is limiting
our options and it's going to get worse
in the future preserve our freedom and
vote in favor of the nature restoration
law tomorrow but colleagues we also all
know that this law has become much more
than just itself in the past month it
has become a symbol a symbol of the
green deal a symbol of constructive
decision making in this Parliament and
it has unfortunately become a symbol of
political games within the Epp on which
strategy they want to go for for 2024
and Mr Weber who is unfortunately not
here right now we can clearly see what
your strategy is going against your own
commission president all of this to me
is a sign of a deep identity crisis
within Epp a shift in decision making
here in this Parliament and for me a
very dangerous development especially as
far right parties and groups and
movements are gaining ground across
Europe colleagues let us vote tomorrow
in favor of the nature restoration law
to show that constructive decision
making in this Parliament is still
possible to show that we stand behind
the green deal and yes also to restore
and protect our nature thank you very
much
foreign
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen
Victor Auburn supported this in Council
I say that to the left this proposal is
not a good one it's contradictory
yes it's good for uh the birds that are
disappearing it's good for the water but
it's very diffic makes life very
difficult for farmers and it brutally
infringes upon the prerogatives of
member states and it generates a cost
burden in
in Council
some of the problems were eliminated
thank goodness for example the power
given to the ngos but the commission
France France where are you
decarbonization on a global level isn't
bringing us anything
uh China is riding a wave it's still hot
everywhere and our own situation is
getting worse
we have a divided house now and we only
have ourselves to blame
[Music]
for the ID group we're going to hear
from Aurelia benue thank you Mr
President rapport
the European commission and the
left have come up with an absolutely
crazy idea which is bad for farmers and
bad for the member states
there were members who wanted an impact
analysis who were threatened
by the commissioner responsible for the
green deal this is scandalous and
anti-democratic we have an imminent food
crisis and you still have these utopian
pipe dreams you're sacrificing our
Farmers on the altar of your ideology
why do you want to meddle with the urban
policy of Our member states it's up to
the member states to decide how they
organize their towns and cities and
certainly not a commission that thinks
it has exclusive power over all policy
areas forests are also National Business
the European commission therefore has no
legitimacy in this respect this text was
rejected in three committees and the
left are now uh in an undemocratic way
bringing the matter uh back to plenary
with amendments
thank you Mr confound for your very uh
useful comments that the rejection of
this text must be definitive in order to
send a clear message to the European
commission and to the left I say yes sir
to the preservation of Nature and
farmland but no to this absurd and
oppressive proposal from the European
commission it's about time that you
stopped hurting our Farmers stop
damaging the interests of Our member
states in the interest of your lobbies
and on the basis of your ideology
for the left
ladies and gentlemen last week was the
hottest week
for 120 000 years
80 percent of soil and Waters have been
devastated by the crazy exploitation of
uh the uh
Planet a quarter of birds have
disappeared
nature restoration should enjoy the
majority here because nature can't
thrive on a dead Planet but the right
and the extreme white are trying to take
this law and turn it into a
a whole
ethic and how to approach this what
about science
what about what is going on outside
rolling the red carpet out for climate
uh
deniers
we can see that they're
all sorts of
ramifications that this will have like
upending the whole environmental
policies of the EU what about people
trying to save the planet well Mr
seizure knee
we heard from Mr Mac horn
talking about the environment he
basically started the ball rolling of
this whole situation and it is the
voting behavior of your members who
allowed it to be rejected in the
environment committee any vote against
will bring us closer to the abyss
let's not forget what's going on with
the young people and young protesters
because history will catch you up it's
only the 10th of uh July it's 37 degrees
out so let's vote in favor of the nature
restoration law
s
and now representing the non-attached
Maria Angela dancing
president's commissioner today I feel
and we all should feel a great
responsibility the last flooding in
Emilia Romania caused 15 deaths and 9
billion Euro of damage
I can still see before me the floods in
Genoa
when I was doing extra General those
who've lived through such experiences
have felt today as they did then a great
sense of impotence and inadequacy for
not having been able to prevent the
effects of such disasters we must not
give up scientists associations and
millions of citizens are asking us to
take action climate change is not an
inescapable process restoring degraded
land and protecting biodiversity are the
tools
we're not impervious to economic
arguments but we must keep a distance
from the pressures of special interests
and today we can reverse course
president I would like to make an appeal
to my Epp and renew colleagues do not
follow the far right and climate change
deniers Vote for This measure it is an
investment to secure the future of our
children
the five-star movement will therefore
vote in favor of this measure and
support it with great conviction
colleagues
I come from a rural area
and the people in my
region
have a completely different view from
those in the Brussels bubble
more than more different than ever
I have spoken to Mayors and to Farmers
and in Germany they are clearly against
this law I've spoken to The Operators of
Hydro power stations they are worried
about this legislation because it's
going to make it difficult for Hydro
power stations
other
projects are going to other projects
which are part of the energy transition
are going to be made more difficult by
this proposal
why are
why is there a divide in the German
greens at the moment
because there are those who are in favor
of the energy transition and those who
are in favor of every last bird species
unfortunately now we have climate change
we have to fight it together we can't
pretend that we're in the situation we
were in 70 years ago
many definitions are unclear it's a pig
in a poke this piece of text
I think we should listen to what the
people are saying in the rural areas we
should listen to the people who are
outside today we should say nature
restoration yes we can nature
restoration law no we can't let's vote
against this proposal
[Applause]
a blue card
Mikhail blossom
Peter Lisa you voted in favor of the
climate law you voted in favor of Lulu
CF 10 of the climate objective comes
through nature how do you want to
achieve that if you vote against this
law if you vote against this law you
vote against climate protection you vote
against the Green deal against the
fonderline project that's not going to
help us meet the climate objectives
thank you Michelle
I'm very happy to answer this question
I'd remind everybody that it was Mikhail
Bloss on behalf of the greens together
with ID and the ecir groups
that were in favor of ditching ets2
people in glass houses shouldn't throw
stones
we believe in cooperation we voted for
Lulu CF yes
310 uh million tons of additional sinks
that was the Epp position we want
incentives we don't want the coercive
measures that are proposed here we don't
correct colleagues
we have
many people wanting to speak that's
understandable the issue is important
I think therefore given how many
speakers there are we don't have too
many blue card
interventions I can only take one at a
time but we have such a long speakers
list with all the opinions represented
let's make sure that everyone on the
speakers list can be taken so a maximum
of one blue card per speaker and then
only when it's absolutely necessary
this is already a very emotive and
important subject the next speech is
Muhammad shahim
a
president no thank you
president nature restoration is all well
and good because nature is our future
about healthy soils
and where we can produce sustainable
food for the future and we have seen
problems of climate change but
unfortunately we've seen this
legislation hijacked by political
interests we've seen that the Epp is not
looking at the content and the proof of
this is that the chair and the vice
chair of that group are holding a press
conference at the same time that this
debate is going on as scandalous that
this is happening
because don't don't be mistaken this
nature restoration law is just as
important for biodiversity for the
crisis in biodiversity as the climate
agreement was as well climate and
biodiversity are two sites of the same
coin
so
we can see the Epp picking up cuddles
against this as a political
approach and that's what happens when
you drive a wedge like this
and we've seen this in the Netherlands
it's been going on for a long time
polarization of views and false
dichotomies and this is happening in
Europe as well now
the CDA and a number of other parties
are trying to get votes but they're
basically chasing votes by moving to the
right and what's the cost of this the
cost is our nature our future and that's
cynical politics that's politics that
you should be ashamed of because it's
very simple what we should be voting
here do we want to leave the world
better than the state We inherited it in
so I think it's very straightforward I
hope that tomorrow will be all voting in
favor of this to make progress go
forward Adelante
and bought this
Rodriguez Ramos next it's Miss Rodriguez
thank you president outside this chamber
the nature restoration bill at law I
reached with a lot of support to
Scientific community
large companies in renewable energy
companies the people of Europe
especially the young people of Europe
the committee of the regions mayors
uh presidents of regions Council
majority in Council
that's what's happening outside the
chamber so the problem is here the
problem is inside this chamber
we're talking about 80 percent of our
ecosystems
being in a deplorable State and
requiring restoration and the fact that
they don't have any arguments is plain
before us Labor's not here
tomorrow we need to ensure that this law
has a mandate to enter trilogs
our growth depends on it
not only does this law not
prevent
development what it does is
make our model more sustainable in terms
of ecosystems it doesn't undermine food
security seventy percent of agricultural
soils in Europe are undergoing
continuous erosion and what this law
does is not only help ecosystems and
habitats it also affects citizens rights
today and tomorrow I've heard people say
we need more scientific evidence before
we Act
well I'm sorry we've got plenty of it
we've got plenty of scientific evidence
what we're lacking is political courage
Miss o'bri don't pursue The Wrong Enemy
tomorrow my group renew will have a firm
commitment to ensuring that this law can
move forward
thank you utopolis is next
president
thank you Mr President commissioner
colleagues
it
Europe's nature is suffering 80 percent
of ecosystems are in a poor State 1500
species on the red list and bird
populations are falling
I'm old enough to know what it was like
when the sky was full of skylarks
the commission and the constructive
groups in this Parliament have come up
with a law to relieve the pressure on
nature
to allow room for pollinators to
safeguard diversity which protects us
from the rapid climate change that we're
facing
without healthy Eco systems we cannot do
climate protection we need healthy
forests we need carbon sinks we need to
revitalize our
ecosystems for the purposes of climate
adaptation
we've seen what happens when a Rivers
burst their Banks this should be a
lesson to us
and right now cities are climate change
hot spots and that's why we need this
law in order to protect citizens from
these changes in these threats
there's another possibility you can say
oh there's there's no problem
um
the trouble is if you don't have
water and you don't have oxygen then the
fact that you can drive your car around
doesn't really give you much
the EPP
is talking about Villages being
demolished and hydropower stations being
dismantled that's not in the text and
this idea to of restoring everything to
how it was 70 years ago is nonsense it's
not in the text it's pure populism
we need a
long-term food security stop Mr Weber
stop campaigning at the expense of uh of
the the citizens and our safety
we need to do this for future
generations and tomorrow it's decision
time
and what is
foreign
thank you president
commissioner in Marion Heim a village in
the east of our country there's a big
problem
there's a busy dangerous road that goes
straight through the village
now the bypass that would relieve that
Village traffic won't be coming anytime
soon now an important reason for this
alongside the shortage of funds is the
suffocating nature 2000 legislation
which even makes Road Safety subordinate
to Nature
president
if we're to vote in favor of the nature
restoration law tomorrow we will be
generating comparable situations all
over Europe as a result
uh rural areas will simply have to shut
up shop
the rule of Primacy nature always comes
first will then apply to many other
areas outside nature 2000 areas
and then the proposal doesn't take
population density into account at all
and that makes things all the more
complicated nature is important but the
commission's approach is simply not good
enough
let us support Grassroots initiatives
let's give the regions enough
flexibility to be able to take their own
responsible decisions more meddling from
Brussels is not going to help the
amendment to reject merits all your
support thank you thank you
foreign
with all its unrealistic and dangerous
legislation following the industrial
emissions directive revision
now we have all the farmers being
attacked by the commission with its
nature restoration law
generations of farmers before us have
worked at this land preserved it and
transmitted it to Future Generations
it's crazy to restore
ecosystems by uh 20 or 50. this will be
a disaster for our future
the plans for Rivers would be fatal
every member State should decide for
itself this text has been rejected three
times so a clear message has been sent
by this Parliament stop these crazy
environmental plans which are destroying
our uh agriculture all we're doing is
creating even more pollution with your
plans
Mr Pito
Francaise
you can stay where you are I'm going to
speak French
I'm a farmer you know that
what threatens food sovereignty what
threatens uh farming and of farmers
Revenue
is not more nature it's not the climate
balance it's using more pesticides it's
using uh more artificial fertilizers
that's what bad for food sovereignty in
the future of farmers so Mr libretto
it's perfectly possible to have
biodiversity and farming
what is your question
foreign
I never said we need more pesticides I
agree that there can be measures which
take into account environmental concerns
we should be looking at polluting
industry we should look at the countries
that have replaced nuclear with coal
once we've done that we can talk about
farming may I see Mr Mick Wallace the
floor is yours
thank you
firstly thanks to society staff for the
great work on the legislation
the choice of global biodiversity
collapse is real
the scientific consensus is that if we
do not take dramatic action within the
next decade we may face irreversible
damage to the natural world and the
collapse of our societies
the silence the science is absolutely
clear the biggest threat to our food
security to the future of Agriculture to
the very Persistence of humanity are the
climate and biodiversity crises the
nature restoration law can help to
address the board last week in pimonte
in Italia it was unprecedented damage to
grapevines and hazelnuts
in some cases total crops were wiped out
by hazelnuts bigger than golf balls and
it was 30 degrees
the nature restoration law is not
perfect it will not radically alter our
utterly broken economic system which
depends on Perpetual extraction of
finite resources to fuel infinite
expansion and unfortunately any
Parliament text we end up with after
divorce this week is likely to be quite
a bit weaker than the commission's
proposal
it won't be ideal but I am hopeful to
have the negotiations with the council
we will have a legal framework that is
workable and that sufficiently addresses
the biodiversity crisis
our future depends on us the nature
restoration law is an existential
necessity
[Applause]
floor is yours
Mr President dear colleagues this is the
NM the nth green deal proposal here in
the hemicircle none of them have been as
divisive as the one we have in front of
us on nature restoration
everybody in this hemicycle accepts the
importance of restoring nature but we
must say this
the current proposal in its current form
is impracticable the European Commission
on the left
and their
proposals put the livelihood of farmers
at risk and can reduce food production
by 30 in Europe obviously the food
prices are going to rise Farms will go
bust and will become dependent of third
countries Mr commissioner it is very sad
and unacceptable that Brussels has not
come forward with a proposal for a fund
that would help farmers instead of
intimidation and backdoor deals we
should come back to the negotiating
table yeah
thank you president
commissioner the farming and Fisheries
sector crying out for a help if you go
out of the chamber you can hear their
voices listen they feel they've been
abandoned stop disproportionate
legislation that runs counter to their
interests that puts their way of life
and food Security in danger
farmers and Fishers feel persecuted
they're being blamed for climate change
while the commission ignores significant
evidence
efforts which they've made to reduce CO2
emissions so it's a yes to a nature
restoration law it's an laudable
objective but it shouldn't be done this
way we Face these Global challenges and
this legislation is being uh now absent
we'll find it very difficult to explain
to Farmers in Castillo Leon and the rest
of Spain why she's turning her back on
them yes we have to support the
environment but we need to support the
economy and Society farmers and
fishermen are equally vulnerable
commissioner you cannot restore nature
without farmers
you cannot restore nature against
Farmers against the interests of farmers
so
withdraw this law and put forward a law
which does combine Environmental
Protection with the production of
quality food for all citizens thank you
foreign
colleagues
I want to speak as a member of the
agriculture committee there are two
demonstrations outside
they want to create a situation that
it's Farmers versus non-farmers but it's
not Farmers versus non-farmers it's
about power
and
the idea of teaming up with the far
right to stay in power versus the future
on the one hand you have the Epp the
Euro Skeptics and the extreme right they
would get rid of nature rather than
losing power
so to those who've really switched their
brains on
please stay with science stay with the
future stay with the future Generations
this is not about Farmers versus
non-farmers this is about common sense
against Power
[Applause]
foreign colleagues
commissioner
this week we have a twofold
responsibility which is a grave one
firstly save nature
and if I could turn to my colleagues on
the right and the center right
if you don't want to listen to the
unanimous view of scientists
that this law deserves being defense
being defended listen to Hunters Hunters
are in favor of this law
their Association is listen to the
agri-foods association they're in favor
of this law because they know that the
main threat to effective food production
is the is endangered species and
endangered pollenisers
our economy depends on the services that
come from nature so listen to the
economic forecasts too
the second part of our responsibility is
that we have to
stand up against the far right and not
the Epp should not get into bed with the
far right that's killing European
democracy it's killing the spirit of
compromise
which has been there since the beginning
of the green deal don't let far-right
populism and fake news in we've seen
these lies around for a year now and
you've
fallen for them Hook Line and Sinker and
pass them on in this chamber so save
nature and stand up against the far
right if we come together I believe we
can prevail
[Applause]
Mr Buddha
you are on the speakers list hence I
will not be taking your blue card
question and I'll give the floor to Mr
Bass a coat ciao making nature healthy
again is key and an ally in the fight
against climate change and disease
outbreaks it is at the heart of our
European green deal
I'm quoting Ursula Von the lion
the EU nature restoration law is a
generation's opportunity to take
concrete and effective action
more than 100 companies making that
statement last week
ex making clear how important this
nature reservation law is were there
concerns did we do negotiations yes
there were concerns some cities had
their concerns but now Euro cities
representing a huge bunch of cities in
Europe is tweeting we need the Nature
restoration law is this against Farmers
no the caring farmers are making very
clear we need the Nature restoration law
so Epp what happens you walk away from
the negotiation table you tweet about
Santa Claus it's all very funny but
let's get back to reality let's take
this vote and it's finally time you
support nature restoration and this law
thank you
foreign
Mr President commissioner
all of this shouting all of this
blackmail makes clear that this is a bad
regulation it's not well thought through
it attacks nature and attacks people if
something is impossible impracticable
then you get the opposite effect to what
you wanted this is a bad regulation it
interferes with privacy and property
we're not going to reduce the
temperature in Strasbourg if we take
land away from Farmers Farmers Foresters
and Fishers love nature
at least as much
as those who pretend to care for nature
this is a bad regulation because it
hands too many powers to the European
commission which is going to be
monitoring reporting and taking
decisions itself
so on on the one hand uh things are
prohibited and then more things are
prohibited I think you should all go and
see some Farmers to find out how to
really care for nature
Silvia
now miss Sylvia Lima has the floor
the nature restoration regulation is
nothing more than a huge X preparation
and destruction program
formerly there were 15 million farms at
2 400 that's and 3.6 million are left
and it's your that's not even taking
into account your huge Miss sold nature
laws
let's not forget there's food that has
to be flown halfway around the world
before we get it on our plates we need
to support domestic Farmers by keeping
arable land not by getting rid of it and
you're well aware of this but instead of
looking at
objective arguments you'd rather say oh
it's the Epp oh you need to
um
you've been adopting the afd right-wing
ideology
but this green red ideology doesn't just
show your lack of ideas but is quite
simply politically
anti-democratic and shameful more dicks
Mr Mr Sylvia muldig it's the next
speaker
Mr President
the scientific Community has been saying
for years uh
that uh
the threat to to biodiversity and
climate change are linked and we have to
deal with both
nature if it is healthy could help us
but at the moment it is not
what's happening now is an extraordinary
level of a species Extinction including
uh pollinators we're seeing
if the
scientific Community saying that the
loss of nature is a threat to food
supply and farmers
the biodiversity strategy will be just
empty words without this law we have to
stop the loss of nature nature deserves
better than this uh short-sighted
politicking
thank you very much the next speaker I
can't see him actually so I'll give the
floor now to Herbert Dorfman instead
thank you president commissioner ladies
and gentlemen
I think when we're looking at making new
legislation in this house we need to ask
ourselves whether it's going to respect
subsidiarity and bring added value and
for this nature restoration law the
answer is clearly no
the local authorities are responsible
for being stewards of the land and by
bringing in these sort of bands we are
abusing that power I don't think
Brussels knows better than individual
local authorities on what is sensible or
not
and of course when it comes to
agriculture
we can't blame them for the destruction
of nature 10 of production needs to be
withdrawn from food security is
something that the commission is saying
is not going to be affected well if the
other 90 were to be more efficient it
would be but is this really something
that makes sense does it make sense to
try and produce more sustainably across
the board in agriculture but that's what
we have the cap for the common
agricultural policy we're spending
billions each year on this we're going
to endanger this if we're going to start
introducing these new legal standards
of course there's a question of property
law as well that's being abused here
this should be sent back to the
commission thank you Mr Dorfman
company
uh
I think you need to put your headphones
on
okay
I believe that you and all of us here
want to protect nature you said that the
commission proposal brings no added
value I know that you're very familiar
with agriculture
could you say
if farmers
are going to get a a better life and
nature is going to be better off what
would we need to do
thank you foreign
well thank you very much
during the course of this long debate on
the common agricultural policy I've
certainly been very committed to the cap
having aspects of sustainability
inherent in it that we have Eco schemes
that we have Eco agricultural schemes
about a third of our total expenditure
for cap is is being spent on more
sustainability and I think that is an
efficient path that we need to continue
to tread in the current reform and
future reforms that will give Farmers
more possibilities and help nature
better thank you very much to Mr Madison
he was and he he asked for a blue cut I
will say you aren't the speaker's list
so it December
thank you our next speaker is Mr
President
thank you Mr chair
although I have been involved in
politics for a long time I cannot accept
the fact that to some colleagues the
upcoming elections and votes are more
important than the future of our
children I cannot understand the
Breakneck move of the right parties
which up until a few months ago couldn't
stop talking about the importance of
balancing sustainable development
policies and the fisheries and I'm
stressing for the hundredth time no one
wants to take the livelihood from the
fishermen or force them to move their
vessels and change their profession
quite the contrary
nature restoration is not a wish it is a
dire necessity this regulation offers
enough time to member states to prepare
the national restoration plans and start
adopting adequate measures
and only in those areas which need it
most so let me say to all the
manipulators out there Article 5 pair
one is going strongly against you and to
conclude vote against the nature
restoration is a vote against Common
Sense against food security against
preservation of natural beauties and
against the survival of European
fishermen and at the same time it is the
most primitive form of selfishness and
political scheming
plus yours
is travels
the president
before I start I just remind you that
you let committee videos go over the
time with 7 minutes and 24 seconds
so please give us a chance
In The Same Spirit
I don't like emotional debates
and this debate has been very emotional
and therefore we don't see the facts as
they are
in all cases of shared competence
the commission is forced
according to
articles four and five of the of the
treaty
to show that the problem is better sold
on EU level than the members the
membership level membership level that
leads by the Logics of things to a
one-size-fits-all and that's the very
problem
of this proposal
the nature in Finland is not being
killed
in 80 percent as has been stated here
the nature in in the Dutch in the
Netherlands is probably being killed
because you have per square kilometer
500 Dutch persons
in Finland we have probably 17.
so you have different circumstances in
different member states
and therefore this is not taken into
account in this proposal and that's
creating the immense problems we have
and we're going to have a very hard
debate in the renew it's not easy to be
the king maker and therefore the rest of
the seven minutes I leave to the next
speaker thank you
from Mr Lambert
you know I respect you a lot uh you
mentioned Finland the nature Finland is
not being destroyed the entire climate
strategy
I know but okay what you mean is that
basically Finland does not have the same
problem as the Netherlands I agree it's
a different country but the entire
climate strategy of your country is
predicated on your Forest absorbing 20
million tons of carbon every year and
the way they are exploited today makes
that they emit carbon instead of
absorbing it you have to solve this
right
[Applause]
the good colleague from Belgium
has the wrong information about a
Finnish Forest because there was a
report that the Finnish Forest is
emitting more
then that was controlled several times
and showed that this is not the case so
when you start the debate finish for us
with me you better stay by the facts
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
colleagues
we are losing biodiversity we know the
problems with the climate change hence
the nature of restoration law is crucial
and must be adopted every member of this
Parliament has
their say on the future of humanity
we're seeing the degradation of soil
we're seeing forests burning we're
seeing lives being lost
it is
vital therefore to adopt this law which
you on the right and the hard right want
to destroy
what are you going to tell your children
that we sacrificed nature in order to
unite the European right that is
irresponsible and criminal so to the
colleagues on the right I say please
disregard what your leaders are saying
and vote in favor of this law speaker is
thank you president colleagues the
European commission is showing that it
has no Scruples about imposing its will
on Europeans and destroying our primary
sector using exposed environmental
concern as an excuse the so-called
nature restoration law says it's about
restoration but actually it's
threatening a significant proportion of
our arable land which has already been
severely curtailed by previous
legislation our arable and livestock
Farmers with their Millennial experience
and
vital
know-how being chased off the land
because of this green excuse the forest
fires in Spain are because the law
prevents Forest cleaning dams and
reservoirs are destroyed when we need
water in a drought we're not going to
allow you to risk our ability to feed
ourselves and take us to the brink what
we need is strong governments that bring
some common sense back to our policies
rather than indulging in climate
fanaticism this
thank you very much Mr and uh
in the debate we're having here
it seems that the right is being pitted
against the left that's a question of
the crisis of biodiversity how come
we've come to this state of play or
common agriculture policy column
Fisheries policies
these are now in the purview of the EU
when you're blaming the for the farmers
and the Fishers for the state of nature
well they're the ones who are having to
assume the rules that you have been
producing
I think it's more the commission that's
responsible for the state of nature and
now to give the Kim the court of justice
a blank check so that they can
aggregate more Powers unto themselves is
ridiculous
in local authorities in towns and and
Villages but those of us who live in
rural areas as well we're the ones who
can save nature not in Strasbourg or in
um Brussels
being flan against the next speaker this
to work for all our futures for that to
happen we need to be honest with Farmers
on what they will have to do if it is
going to cause a problem then we have to
admit it in the case of re-establishing
habitats Article 4 paragraph two
depending on how a member stage
interprets it Farmers could be prevented
from farming their land that's not
scaremongering that's my honest
interpretation I have tabled two
amendments in order to guarantee that
when and if this regulation comes into
effect that those farmers who Farm in an
extensive sustainable way are protected
between now and when the trialogs are
concluded this must be dealt with thanks
to the repertoire repertoire for your
email on this and I'll be talking to you
we also need to fund this we've been
told by the WWF that the regulation will
create 1.8 trillion in public funds yet
we can find any new public money in
Switzerland they found the money in
Switzerland Switzerland there's very
little controversy because farmers are
taken care of to financially match what
Switzerland gives to Farmers for nature
the EU would only need a mere 0.4
trillion every six years cheap in
comparison to 1.8 trillion thank you
very much thank you very much
the next speaker is Mr Jurg moyton
a president
Mr President colleagues
we're talking today about the nature
restoration law
the commission's proposed
seems okay you can't be against nature
but look at the detail of the text
and then
as so often you see that it's well
presented ideological nonsense
it's about 20 percent of our territory
being turned into Wilderness despite
having been used for farming this is far
removed from reality and highly
dangerous it's a danger to our farming
it's a danger to our food security
in future we need affordable fruit and
vegetables Regional products on our
tables we shouldn't be creating
obstacles for our farmers
in the interest of uh farming and nature
protection we should vote against this
text on Wednesday Fiat is
thank you president
less than a year left in our term of
office so it's good that this week we're
having a debate and out a vote on the
nature restoration law
it's very clear
which interests are being represented
for our
population our electorate obviously if
something isn't up to the Mark we need
to rework it
we're not saying that it's either this
or an ecological collapse that's not
true and these sort of arguments aren't
helping anybody not least the climate
and the environment we want to
strengthen biodiversity but we need to
have objectives that are realistic and
that are feasible
and I don't think that something can be
said of this proposal
the collected left-wing have said that
they're not interested in trying to get
everybody on board on this journey
towards a sustainable Society instead
they want to have a debate where
they can denigrate those people don't
think as they do and I don't think it's
worthy of this Parliament nor the
European environmental work that is so
important
also you're ignoring those people who
are to administer and be stewards of
the land
they're the ones who we're dependent of
the moderates and the Epp will also put
people at the center of our policies and
we in our political group believe that
the farmers are part of the solution not
part of the problem thank you
thank you for our colleague
thank you very much now miss helium
fritzon
thank you
president commission no
as with many swedes I have a deep and
close relationship with nature from our
high mountains in the North
to the scanian plains with rapeseed in
the South nature is our most important
resource we have to look after it for
our children and our grandchildren we
need to bolster nature that's important
for the green transition
and that's why it is a pillar of the
European green deal and that's why it's
so important that we do work hard to
produce legislation that will strengthen
nature and at the same time
promote an active Swedish Agriculture
and Forestry policy and unfortunately
the right wing conservatives have left
the negotiating table and have abdicated
responsibility for for the future now is
not the time that you want to do as in
Sweden to shift to the right to stop the
green transition we are legislators we
stand up for compromises that will help
Swedish nature for sustainable nature
environment and agriculture do you
accept the blue cut
foreign
restoration law has praiseworthy
objectives to strengthen biodiversity
and that's why I understand it sounds
good to vote in favor of this proposal
but it's all too well the case that MEPS
are more concerned about what sounds
good rather than what actually is good
we are legislators
we're not political influencers
this proposal would have devastating
consequences for the heartlands of
Sweden and I think the Swedish social
democrats should be more concerned with
what Farmers Foresters
and local authorities are doing here
rather than trying to be following
political influences like Greta thunbo
yeah
well thank you Miss kriptidon for that
question we are legislators that is why
we have a responsible responsibility to
negotiate I want to work for Swedish
interests in the nature restoration law
by negotiating on compromises the most
important progress here would be to
increase flexibility in the legislation
so that we can say that the member
states needs are being met and also the
various needs in various regions
National restoration plans are
absolutely essential for this
legislation and that's how we protect
viable Agriculture and Forestry in every
single member state is
Bohemia
thank you Mr President commissioner
biodiversity is vital to life and so it
should be strengthened it's a great pity
that the commission has produced uh an
unrealistic proposal for a nature
restoration law disregarding member
states and failing to meet this
objective and the way the commission has
operated has also not been appropriate
it's no surprise therefore that many
members of this Parliament want to
reject this proposal
it is wrong
to apply
one-size-fits or
a country with 75 percent of its land as
a forest with a Clean Water Resources
should not be the country paying the
most and why should a private property
rights be trampled on quite clearly
we need to reject this proposal and the
commission needs to come up with
something better
this is what keep it not happy
Mr Holmgren thanks America tall man
thank you very much
president it's getting quite hot here
it's hot outside it's going to be maybe
37 38 degrees this afternoon I don't
know if there's a something symbolic to
be read into that but if not this year
then next year we will see the one and a
half degree increase that we'll see for
the first time and that is really a
signal about the fever that the Earth is
suffering so when you want to have pain
relief and reducing uh the fever then
nature respiration is the best medicine
we have to have this nature restoration
law in effect as everyone here knows for
many in the parliament this discussion
has been a political tug of war whether
the conservative
group wants to
accommodate the right wing that we've
seen in both in Sweden and Finland and
that's why I'm very surprised to see how
many in the liberal group are choosing
the right wing side for example the
center party that is liberal and green
when I was growing up and today at least
this week it seems to be neither nor
thank you
our next speaker is Mr Pedro fioreche
illustrations
nature restoration was rejected by Agri
Pesca and envy
going Beyond mature 2000
if you look at what has happened in
Italy
as a result of nature nature of 2000
we've seen drugs and prostitution
rushing into abandoned areas and
violations of
principles of privacy were also
throwing subsidiarity and member states
the sovereignty down the toilet to
commissioner I would say that the
25 kilometers of free River well how's
that going to be used for
renewable energy production is that
going to be our hydroelectric uh
strategy
we need to look at agricultural
production as well as the environment we
do want restoration of nature but
we should not become accomplices to the
destruction of the rights of the
citizens of Europe and finally a
personal comment
if I heard carried out the environmental
impact
study of the commission applying it to
the the social and economic Dimensions
when I was at school I would have
flunked all of my uh final exams so go
back and do better
thank you very much
the next speaker it's Mr Madison one
minute please stick to the time
otherwise I'll have to interrupt
interrupt you
thank you very much
first of all
I'm not sure how many people here have
read this uh regulation from beginning
to end there's been a lot of emotive
talk people four people against people
who want to save the planet uh
I've read this regulation many times and
I have a number of questions
it's said that this isn't going to hurt
our farmers
and yet by 2030
peat extraction must uh
stop on 30 percent of uh peat box
uh now Pete is a vital ingredient for
Farmers how is that going to be
compensated by 2050 according to the
regulation half of Pete areas have to be
restored to bog
and
who is going to compensate the Foresters
for the fact that they're going to lose
their Timber as a result of the left
wanting their utopian bogs this is going
to hurt farmers it is going to uh hurt
Foresters and I wonder who is going to
pay for this we are looking at society
as a whole you are thinking in terms of
your utopian dreams thank you
there's a blue card for you Mr Madison
blue card but foreign
to compensate
we all know that if we do not expose in
the climate change especially on
biodiversity the cost is going to be at
least 10 fold to our economies and
Farmers I'm just asking who should
compensate and out of which money we are
going to compensate then the nature
destruction
well that's another question we all know
that all the money has to be part of
taxpayers so it has to be from our own
of course not from our pockets because
most of us that you care about the money
but
the ordinary people has to pay higher
price for the food they have to buy a
higher price for the traveling the
higher price for the fuel for the
traveling to the work in the morning so
it comes from the ordinary people only
because that we are believing that we
can change the climate there's no doubt
that there's a climate change the only
question is that how can we really
affect and are we really changing some
way in the climate change if we're just
saying to the food producers no you're
our enemies you shouldn't produce any
meat anymore because you are just
destroying the planet that's the real
problem thanks a lot
foreign
[Music]
law the title sounds really well and who
wouldn't agree but the truth is that
this is just another idiocy
which we've seen so many times in this
house the only real objective of this
law is to confiscate private property
and to take away land from Farmers
the ultimate objective is to
take away
organic food from citizens so citizens
will not be able to eat normal food
this rule should have been entitled
taking away food from the mouths of
European citizens
in communism there was a little dignity
so the laws on confiscation of private
property were called laws on
confiscation and now you call them laws
on restoring nature on restoring the
planets but this is Idris and
thank you
one minute 30 Mr Brown Hoover secretary
Madam president commissioner we are now
debating on the nature restoration law
and tomorrow we're going to vote
but uh reading the title and reading the
individual points they seem to be
different things this text should have
been called something else
it could have been uh called the
abandonment of forests and Fields or it
could have been called Farmers
expropriation law
you if you want to protect nature look
at what farmers are doing I'm a farmer
in Austria and I know how to farm my
fields and we saw the demonstrations
outside the tractors outside the farmers
outside there worried that they're not
being heard
but I'm afraid
we're not going to be able to achieve
for this by abandoning our Fields our
farmland
there's a
a contradiction also in terms of energy
we want more renewable energy and yet
we're going to make it impossible to
build a new hydroelectric power station
just because it's in a nature protection
area
commissioner I think you have to take
these concerns seriously
everything we're deciding here is
already covered by 23 regulations we
don't need another one we're in favor of
nature protection but this is not the
way to do it we need a better proposal
thank you there's a blue card for you Mr
benhuber but the blue card requester
already is on the speakers list so I'm
I'm going to move straight on to Mr
hoytoma
no my apologies
bookheart Denton
thank you very much Madam president I
think many of us here want to look at
the concerns uh inherent in this
proposal for nature restoration but
we're looking at this being a question
of whether we're going to reject out of
hand that the European parlance the only
institution that's blocking this so
refusing to go forward rather than
finding Solutions it would be an
important
vote if it weren't just about nature
restoration but because it's also about
whether majority of this house is going
to support the right-wing course of
Manfred Weber looking at leaving the
negotiating table in the European
Parliament a fake news campaign that Mr
Trump would be envious of these are
strategies we've seen in Italy Spain and
Sweden they're forming alliances with a
right not to resolve issues but to try
and get post to try and gain an
importance we've heard from some of the
Epp people who've been critical towards
this come back to the negotiating table
and make sure that this law becomes
reality
thank you
thank you very much president
commissioner ladies and gentlemen
nobody's against nature I grew up on a
farm in the midst of nature
biodiversity in Europe and in the rest
of the world needs to be protected so
it's not a question of whether we're
going to do it or not but how we're to
achieve this in best way the proposal
from the European Commission on paper
sounds fantastic in reality it would
just slow things down necessarily
including on nature restoration
countries such as the Netherlands are
already shutting down
we're seeing that the Netherlands is
being dragged into a morass and it's
this proposal that's brought us there
permits for building houses for
agricultural Holdings and various other
projects cannot be produced in time with
the national approach for nature
restoration what are the promises for
the coming decades well if this nature
illustration law is adopted these
promises will not be able to be
fulfilled all the legislative proposals
that I've looked at in my time in
Parliament this is the one that will
have the biggest impact on people back
home
this is a proposal we cannot accept
without looking at the negative
ramifications even if we're talking
about nature restoration thank you
thank you Mr veins that's the floor
Madam president commissioner
this is the biggest wave of Extinction
since the end of the dinosaurs every
hour we are losing three species
I
who have been seeing what the right have
been putting on Twitter about how this
is all nonsense
it's it's essential
to uh protect nature it's not uh crazy
as you're trying to make out it's very
important to protect our nature to
protect our Rivers
I really disagree with everything you
say and The Greening of our cities we
need it to prevent people protect people
from uh heat waves
you're blocking the green deal you're
blocking the nature restoration law
you're a threat to our Farmers you're a
threat to our food security you're a
threat to human life in cities you're
also threatening the future of our
children and grandchildren listen to
what business is saying listen to what
the farmers are saying and listen to the
people who have the arguments in favor
of the nature restoration law thank you
thank you
thank you very much Madam president
commissioner we're all
interested in the Improvement of
biodiversity but the regulation is bad
for farming bad for forestry bad for
investment as regards farming well
Environmental Protection and
biodiversity are in the common
agricultural policy and about a third of
the cap budget uh more than 100 billion
euro is allocated every seven years to
that
we've also got the Eco schemes for
plants and animals in the cap
farmers are voluntarily doing all of
this and they're getting money for it
and yet in this regulation we have
coercion and not a Euro given for uh
doing these things moreover the
commission isn't saying where the money
is to become from and the commission is
taking on Powers which have no basis in
the treaties so the Polish delegation in
the Eco will be voting against this
regulation thank you
[Music]
there's a blue card
for you Mr kushmiuk
there is a blue card from you for you
from kierga
I'll speak French
of course we're here that's never the
right proposal we should always wait we
should always
change things but let's trust the
farmers as if everything were going well
well I have a question to put to you
when will it be the right time to take
stronger steps will it be the time when
actually things it's too late
let me say again we're all in favor of
biodiversity but these proposals are
obligatory they're administrative and
they're not funded the common
agricultural policy since the 1st of
January of this year takes the opposite
approach it gives incentives and it
grants additional funding to Farmers to
meet the objective that is how we're
going to succeed thank you
Q and this contact that's the floor now
thank you president
commissioner rejected in Fisheries
rejected in agriculture rejected an
environment
full-time lucky
no way Jose we're actually calling on
plenary to ensure it isn't once again
hoping it will be the final time we aim
to reject a regulation that harms
productive activities while hiding
behind the noble intention of Defending
nature less land for Farmers less C for
fishermen less activity for businesses
and fewer European products and jobs for
our citizens these are the heavy
repercussions of the proposals contained
in a regulation permeated with ideology
and counterproductive to Nature itself
it is not what we want and more
importantly it's not what our citizens
and the planet deserve the European
commission should stop selling us out to
third countries
after all they're the only ones who
benefit from this hypocritical
environmentalism thank
you I think one minute now Ms young you
see no sorry I I was uh too quick there
it's such a lively debate I missed a
blue card request did I or not
no we're not accepting the blue card
request
because it's someone who's already
spoken so I shall indeed give the floor
to Mr Yin you see thank you president
honorable members
it's clear for every responsibly
thinking person that it's our common
duty to protect and preserve nature that
is why I welcome the fact that the issue
has become a key issue for political
decision makers however even nature
conservation is no longer free of
fundamentalists and extremists on a
daily basis extremist groups are abusing
the cause to damage property harass
people
and we have politicians
who demand us to take unreasonable and
feasible steps Mr shinkevich is we are
coming both from former socialist
countries we know how it feels when A
Five-Year Plan is pressing us ahead but
are you sure that no that there is a war
raging in the Ukraine and then in
Hungary there is a 40 inflation of food
prices and there is food shortage
when the economic situation is so
unstable do you think it's a good idea
to force such a regulation which has
side effects like increasing the burden
of Garden of farmers I don't think so
I'm not in favor of it
Mr Lins you have the floor
for president in
Madam president commissioner
I have some good news from my homeland
that I brought with me
we have a monitoring exercise in an
intensive
Orchard and fruit growing area in the on
Lake Constance
we have twice as many species of bees
now than was the case in 2010
26 of which were considered
at risk so that's a huge success and
who's achieved that who'd managed to get
this done well it's the farmers
especially the fruit farmers and what
have they done they've increased
the
Wildflower areas in their Orchards
they've had more wild plants that
they've managed to seed
that is the path we need to take
to go this path together with the
farmers that's a question of best
practice commissioner have a look at
this see which regions are more advanced
in these issues see who have turned
around the loss of biodiversity then
come back with a new proposal and in
fact a revision of the nature and
habitats
[Music]
directive
because there are other threats
elsewhere such as the wolf population
these are things that you should be
taking into consideration
thank you Mr s
dear colleagues
the nature restoration law is not about
setting forests on fire or stealing land
from Farmers rather it's about moving in
the direction of sustainable practices
for the conservation and regeneration of
Natural Resources because otherwise
there will be no economic sustainability
nor long-term food security if you
restore sensitive Marine habitats such
as spawning grounds you're not attacking
Fisheries you're ensuring their
long-term survival Farmers know better
than anyone that without living soil
without water without biodiversity
without pollenisers you have no farming
Fishers know that better than anyone
that without fish there's no fishing so
let's stop using these two important
sectors as an excuse to pursue
objectives which are in fact ideological
and merely party political scheming
let's jetters in this rhetoric that a
nature restoration law is a good idea
about the content of this nature
restoration law is bad because what
we'll be voting on tomorrow is the not
even the commission's original uh
proposal this gives member states
flexibility in their actions to find
their restoration plans up to 2030. it's
not the time for demagogy in scheming
it's time to act for the sake of our own
future survival thank you
thank you
Miss Miller has the floor again
ladies and gentlemen commissioner vice
president Mr timmermans never gets tired
of telling us that the regulation on
nature restoration will be a law that
will help our farmers and Foresters well
I'm sorry to have to spell this out in
such Frank terms but it does sound a lot
like an educational campaign from the
last century the children don't
understand but it's all for their best
sometimes you just have to force them to
be happy
only farmers and Foresters are not
little children they are experts in
their area and they can all too well
understand the consequences on their
expertise and their areas of
professionalism of this law yes we need
a law to bolster the resilience of
nature there is climate change that is
happening and we need to adapt ourselves
and nature to this fact but this can
only be successful if we have people on
board especially those who in their
daily lives work with and in nature and
here the commission has failed
completely
thank you president commissioner the
nature restoration law is vital for the
climate it's also necessary for all
Europeans and all
territories of Europe both London see if
you look at the effects of global
warming on the Mediterranean
climatologists are very clear about
this impact it's an exceptional
environmental Heritage we have very high
CO2 absorption capacity but we're losing
our natural environment because of human
activity so we urgently need to act and
Implement rigorous nature restoration
legislation as soon as possible and do
what we can with this law because
without this law it will only be
destruction which will prevail
there is a blue card for you Mr alfonsi
from
Ronka we've had a blue card from his
grappini 2 but uh I can't accept that
because for the same reasons that I gave
in an earlier case that you already have
speaking time so you cannot be given
blue card time you speak Polish
um
are we aware of the fact that companies
are leaving the EU to China the United
States the United Kingdom
we we have a problem with uh
we have a problem with the
interpretation I believe
it's okay no problem
are we aware of the fact that there are
companies big companies leaving the
European Union for China the United
States the United Kingdom
they're moving out because of the tax
burden
this regulation could cause unemployment
in farming and Forestry
things are only going to get worse are
you not worried that these restrictive
measures are going
to lead to higher unemployment which the
European Union will have to deal with
I'd like to hear what you have to say on
the subject thank you
global warming has led to a situation
where we've seen a loss of nature in the
last 50 years in Europe that's had a
terrible impact on
areas of economic activity including
Farmers so we need to reverse course for
the sake of our citizens for the sake of
our economy and well-being
thank you
Mr hackering and how's the floor now
thank you Mr President
we've always said that Finland lives
from its forests and that's still true
this regulation would affect our
forestry industry our farming and
private property as a whole
in some EU countries
forests are just a memory
and they seem to want to damage ours
it is
if this regulation were to be adopted
the government of Finland should ignore
it
I oppose to this I oppose this
regulation as a whole thank you
thank you
Mr Hyder
with this so-called nature restoration
law
I think in truth there's only one thing
we can do with it and it's reject it out
of hand it expropriates farmers
it is gonna
artificially create
shortage of food in Europe and those
countries dependent on Europe it will
bring bottlenecks and lead to an
increase in prices with this nonsensical
draft you see the equally nonsensical
commission with a sort of on the line
that you could get rid of at the same
time these sort of ideologically driven
policies should be got rid of and
rightly so
the policies of this commission have
been destructive we've seen increasing
prices across the board lack of
certainty and product provision of
energy increase unemployment you've just
brought a curse upon Europe every day
that this commission remains in office
is a black day for Europe
thank you very much
Madam president the nature restoration
law
was rejected by Agri MV and the
Fisheries committee those three
committees had a very clear view they
said the proposal was a bad one by a
socialist commissioner timmermans and
while it may have good intentions it is
insufficient and indeed incompetent in
terms of protecting the environment
biodiversity and indeed food Security in
Europe the Epp response is a clear one
we want to protect the planet
and that is why we voted in favor of
dozens of amendments
particularly in relation to the climate
but
in countries such as Portugal has
produced Vision victims in recent years
do we want to see increases in imports
from countries that don't have the same
environmental safeguards do we want to
endanger food security we would call for
a nature restoration proposal that would
actually achieve that aim and
unfortunately you can't count on us to
do it with this
there is a blue card for you from Mr
Silva Pereira
thank you
Lydia perdida
you
saw the fake news campaign
amongst the fake news was the idea that
Forest can be used to combat forest
fires have you actually read the law do
you know the content
because you were engaging in these fake
news campaigns restoration of nature on
the basis of the scientific criteria and
the scientific criteria vary from one
country to another so you'll be aware
that this is fake News why did you lie
thank you for the question
I turn the question back to you have you
read the law
do you understand that this is a
regulation with figures in it targets
which are the same for all member states
so the environmental circumstances of
Portugal are different to the
environmental circumstances of an
Eastern European country a Nordic
country France or Germany so what
happens is that in relation to the
question which you raise you have a
situation where there is conditionality
uh ecological conditionality for
Portugal
if you're so convinced of by what you
say go and talk to the farmers outside
this door demonstrating in front of
Parliament
Mr Vulcan
thank you madam president commissioner
ladies and gentlemen
in this debate
there are a lot of fairy tales
seeing the light of day we can see that
the leadership of the Epp wasn't once uh
shy of calling the commission Father
Christmas and that this was obviously
meant to be humorous but we're looking
at and a
maintaining that this is going to
threaten food security but the opposite
is true it's a question of
renewable energies not being able to be
spread further and that's not true the
needpp we've seen that renewable energy
legislation was decided on here with an
acceleration of extension of Renewables
and this of course completely rejects
out of hand those
claims that they're making now
so let's give up on these fairy tales
let's stick to the facts let's work for
nature restoration and all members of
the eppr call on you to say you can't
turn you back on this vote with us for
nature Restoration in the European Union
thank you
that's the floor
Madam president
commissioner
I'm very worried about the proposals for
farming in Poland
were we to adopt this
we would destroy thousands of farms
this would lead to a major weakening of
Poland's competitiveness on the single
Market
issues
the planning and
we're planning management and monitoring
Provisions are very vague
I understand National authorities would
have to uh
infringe on private property rights
this would seem to conflict with the
aims of other Union policies such as
those to do with food supply chains so
I'll be voting against the commission
proposal
thank you
Mr President commissioner
the nature restoration law is one of the
poorest pieces of draft legislation that
the commission has ever come up with
the impact assessments have been done
badly the
regulation takes away member states of
flexibility
this is not something
that can be carried through just like
that the regulation is too uh
detailed it covers too many areas the
definitions and criteria are vague the
reference year is random from the point
of view of the Mendham States
it's appalling that the greatest damage
is done to the countries that have the
best nature this has to stop this has to
be done again properly we want to
restore nature but first and foremost we
want balance in the legislation thank
you
you know
nature is under pressure and we can see
this now if you drive through Europe
on your way to your holidays
we're seeing that there are fewer and
fewer insects on your windscreen there
are fewer places where you can get water
straight from your tap to for drinking
we're losing species but we can act but
we need to have a political will to act
and the commission has come forth with
this political will and a majority in
Council as well but here in the
parliament the conservative right wing
has decided to jeopardize our future
jeopardize nature
we have to make sure that animals
insects plants and drinking water can be
maintained for the future and that's why
we need to start negotiating now but
conservatives have put the brakes on far
too long now we need to make sure that
nature will actually win it's time for
nature and I hope that we'll vote in
that line tomorrow
thank you
European farmers are anxiously looking
at us
there are 32 regulations that have to be
respected by Farmers there are
restrictions through the common
agricultural policy pesticide use is
down there's inflation the war in
Ukraine and now we are to reduce uh with
this commission proposal to reduce
farmland
and we're seeing that the commission
wants to flood areas that have been
drained with European funding and they
want to to give money to Farmers with
the water buffalo
unfortunately this uh nature restoration
though it sounds good has created the
conflict and protests
you want to sacrifice farming
commissioner
sacrifice farming and food Security on
the altar of your powerlessness it is
very important for us to have a new
proposal based on uh reality and the
partnership approach thank you
thank you madam president
in the Italian Democratic party and in
the Socialist and social Democrats group
we support the nature restoration Lords
vital to uh future because of a degraded
environments including Marine
environments and forests we're fighting
to achieve adequate resources for an
effective green transition with
protection of persons and work whereas
the writers engaged in our geological
Crusade against the environment against
science and against the future
Generations we're seeing
wastage of you funding in the in Italy
greater doomberg and all of the others
who've given us our wake-up call deserve
our thanks politicians started listening
a few years ago
we need to indicate who is responsible
for the sake of the future and we need
to finally take the right decisions for
once and for all
thank you
the floor now goes to Mr helpst Jesus
gazettes is
this law is not consistent with other
laws dealing with the same area policy
we can see on the question of what the
question of good condition is the way
the bands are being brought in is not
dealt with properly in Fisheries for
example
see bed many un
explored are automatically considered to
be in poor condition these aren't
trivial points these are
real evidence of how poorly this has
been drafted and then suddenly the
commission's saying oh offshore wind is
is restoration
now I'm not against offshore wind farms
but to say that a huge concrete block on
the sea floor and kilometers of cables
across the sea floor are part of nature
restoration well it shows that this
hasn't been thought through maybe people
don't care because the objective is
worthy it's got a nice title this law
but shouldn't be something that we seek
to achieve as as members of parliament
and if you have concerns we're being met
with people telling us we're bad people
I'm a Christian Democrat I don't have a
problem with that but the problem is
that you're not getting people on board
and you're actually destroying nature
I was going to give you the floor but no
sorry Mr Herbst there's a blue card for
you
a blue cardinal blue card
please
we have a blue card
for you from the horse
because you don't miss Europe
president Mr hapst you claim to be
defending the Fishers
and the fish but we're seeing the
fishermen fishes being having their
livelihoods destroyed because of
pollution like a fish if you look at cod
in the Baltic Sea the nature restoration
law will allow a solution to be found
for COD
you're also president of the recreation
Fishers Association of recreational
Fishers are in favor of this nature
restoration law Mr Habs what would you
reply to the Fishers when they're no
more marine ecosystems in decent
condition and when the Fishers are going
to have to just give up and go home
as a marketing enough
well you seem to be mixing up
recreational fishing and professional
fishing but leaving that to one side
what I as an MEP uh do and what I do in
my private time are two different things
but this assertion that
in COD when you're talking about that
this is a solution in the Baltic in this
particular law I'm sorry that's far fact
you won't find any scientists who
who will be able to say what the reason
is behind the poor stocks of cod ICS
don't know so in order to say that this
law will improve the plight of the Cod
is something that is a misnomer
sorry okay
if you've finished I'll give the floor
to miss piraki
no problem please
thank you madam chair
Commissioners their colleagues climate
cries is now ongoing that's why we need
the natural resolution law not not as an
additional law to the 23 European laws
on Ray and adoration we have but as the
legal umbrella that will sufficiently
accelerate the protection of Nature and
the restoration of biodiversity putting
at the core of our attention people's
concern and the Amendments we co-sign in
DPP and we have already tabled are
addressing values issues to this
direction
in my opinion their commissioner it is
the council General approach which is a
good basis for negotiation taking into
account the override public interest for
the deployment of Renewables and defense
facilities as well giving the member
states sufficient flexibility
complementary to the requirement of
national restoration plans and in my
country the government of kiryakos
misotagis in Greece has supported
natural Rehabilitation not only in the
council but also in real practice with
various initiatives and projects in
addition we have to ensure that the
proposed financing of measures required
but National declaration law will not
lead in Cuts in other budget lines
starting with common agricultural policy
we need clarifications coming from the
commission a clear wording we need a
compromise on the basis of the general
approach as soon as possible the natural
restoration law should not be a
battlefield in view of the upcoming
European election on the contrary it is
a unique challenge for a real reform to
the protection of Nacho it is our joint
obligation not only to the nature but
also to the Next Generation thank you
thank you
as you know time is against us we have a
lot of requests for blue cards no sorry
we have a lot of requests for catch the
eye we've already had a lot of blue
cards we're moving on to catch the eye
now there's a lot of people on the list
I'll only take one per political group
we'll start with the EPP Mr Burger
thank you
thank you for this excellent debate
which has demonstrated the split down
the middle of this Parliament
The Proposal is a complex one
in Slovenia we have a great deal of
forest and a great deal of Nature and
biodiversity
amazing
it is important to take into account the
differences between member states 10
percent of Farmland is to be taken away
even where there isn't much farming and
how are we going to get rid of all of
these Hydro power stations
and flooding Farmland is not necessarily
a good idea
we need a new proposal
with sensible measures funded measures
and with the support of farmers which we
don't have today
Mercedes
other presidents
thank you madam president
this is crucial to
biodiversity and the European green deal
eighty percent of our ecosystems are in
a poor state
if you have dead soil rather than living
soil then you cannot produce food so
we're talking about
our sustainable agriculture and food
security of the future what we need to
do is invest in restoring nature that is
good for the economy
we get 38 Euros back for every eight
Euros we invest it's an incredibly
sensitive sector for Portugal looking at
indicators for forestry that is a member
State responsibility that's what the
commission proposal says so
we need to shoulder our responsibilities
those who voted against in the
environmental committee
we need
to put this piece into the jigsaw puzzle
to combat climate change and only in
this way will we be able to combat
climate climate change deniers it is
high time to act
thank you
[Music]
if we don't
re-invigorate our ecosystems then we
won't have any farming forestry or
fishing as a result of the climate
crisis
thousands of scientists including myself
have appealed to Parliament
to think about the terrible state of our
ecosystems
what we're seeing
is fake news the Distortion of reality
and a party which stops its people
voting according to their conscience I
hope that in this Parliament we'll have
enough courage and awareness to vote in
favor of ambitious nature restoration
it's crucial it's about life and the
future thank you
foreign
I'm still at a loss to understand how
you can have three committees
agriculture fisheries and environments
that reject a proposal and then still
put it Forward tomorrow it's
meaningless and harmful to Farmers and
fishes and on top of all that they're
saying that funding should come from uh
fisheries and other EU polities so those
in the sector would see their income
drop even further so what are people in
Europe going to
eat it will be Imports we have less
arable and livestock land and have more
photovoltaics and wind farms and so on
what are we going to eat so tomorrow we
need to defend the farming and Fisheries
sectors
the Socialists must be really worried
about the forthcoming general elections
in Spain they're using this Podium to
attack the Epp and Vox it's probably
just because there's a word about the
elections
daily
grazia Presidente what should have been
a discussion about a far more ambitious
program than what we have here if we're
to save the planets and nature has
turned into really one of the Crassus
campaigns of disinformation by
opportunist politicians and a media
completely incapable of holding them to
account members on all sides have been
using it to play to their own audience
and I have to say I find it utterly
demoralizing why is this issue decisive
it's understandable of course that
people would be annoyed with an arrogant
commission and with the botched jobs on
previous EU regulations but that's not a
reason for misrepresenting this one
everyone wants an end to the devastating
yearly droughts and floods everybody
wants consultation predictable incomes
they want to keep Traditions alive they
want to be financially rewarded for
going the extra mile they want to have a
future to look to with bees and bogs and
everything in between Queen we can have
that with this law there can be a just
transition there's no good reason to
vote against us
thank you
and Mr tarabella for the non-attached
thank you very much this proposal nature
restoration is something to stop the
collapse of our ecosystems
and counter the lack of biodiversity the
loss of biodiversity I think saying that
we've said everything I think nature
needs to provide us with the path to the
Future 50 of the members present
thought it was wise to reject this text
they thought it was better or more
beneficial profitable to Panda to the
petrochemical industry and reject the
text
some of the text may be worse than other
parts but from the start of this term of
office the right have been trying to
bury the green deal and stymie
legislation of this nature now if you
want to have a decent future I'd
encourage you to vote in favor of this
she'll now give the floor to
commissioner singervicius on behalf of
the commission
you have the right to reply
president honorable members
I've listened very carefully to your
interventions today and I would like to
thank everybody
for engaging in this important debate
this morning
and I'm glad we are having this broad
public debate on such an important topic
nature deserves this public attention so
what can we take away from today's
debate first
I think it has Illustrated very well
what's at stake it has shown that Stakes
are high and that nature will not allow
us to lose time far too much of Europe's
Nature has now been degraded or
destroyed and it's vital to reverse that
Trend and time is running out and the
world is watching us
so do our children and we all need to
take responsibilities
if we want to deliver on Europe's Global
biodiversity commitments agreed at cop
15 in Montreal in December 2022. if we
want to maintain the role of the EU as a
global climate leader we have to deliver
nature restoration
is not a luxury legislation healthy
ecosystems they are just fundamental
asset of our economy and society and we
cannot simply opt out or postpone
and today I hear again uh that the green
deal is not the nature restoration law
honorable members yes it is
this law is the flagship initiative of
the European green deal nature and
biodiversity is a key pillar and the
equivalent of the climate law for nature
and it is the first dedicated EU legal
proposal on nature since 30 years
you may be surprised to hear this
but to me this debate has shown that an
agreement is possible
if we remain engaged and if we take our
responsibilities
why I'm rather optimistic because most
of your interventions have shown that
there is a willingness to discuss this
law and because even those of you who
claim that this law has to be rejected
have proposed amendments this is
positive and this is what the college's
college islators and co-decision process
is all about and if there is anything to
change or improve commission here is to
discuss and support you this is our role
to facilitate an agreement and this is
what we are determined to do and I'm
optimistic because today I have heard
concerns on issues which have already
been addressed and solved on Council
side and which we have already reflected
in the non-paper on the 8th of June and
in spite of our genuine efforts to
clarify and explain I still hear and
read many misconceptions and
misunderstandings I still hear questions
to which there are very straightforward
answers which we have already provided
to many of you on bilateral basis but
which are more than happy to reiterate
so let me mention just a few of them
misunder
and Mr mato
you raised concern that nature
restoration will impact food security
and that we are going to increase food
imports well the EU food system has
achieved a high level of security and a
wide offer for consumers
and actually 20 of food in the U goes to
waste the challenge is to maintain the
EU agricultural food production
potential to ensure food Security in the
mid to long term and this requires
transition to sustainable food
production and sustainable food system
I'm afraid that not a food availability
is the issue but food affordability
the biggest threat to food Security in
the U.N globally are the combined
interlinked climate and biodiversity
crisis leading to depletion of soil
pollinators loss disaffertification and
drought and this reflected in the very
comprehensive study on the drivers of
food security which commission published
in January so I heard Miss Snyder ask
for data and impact assessment
all data on relation between Health
ecosystem and food security can be found
there
and on food security
I make a plea to all of you who have
expressed concern
to actually look at article 9 of the
proposal and see with your own eyes what
this article is about requirements are
about increasing trends
in indicators
which scientists tell us are the best
proxies to tell us the health of our
agriculture
and member states can set their own
levels to be achieved on those
indicators so when we talk about
Regional Dimension member states
flexibilities they are there
Mr wandra and Mr Dorfman also Mr towards
you expressed concern that the proposal
would put member states into a straight
jacket
the opposite is true it provides for a
large degree of flexibility and
subsidiarity it will be four member
states to decide which Restorations
measures they wish to put in place where
and when
and the proposal as member states to do
this together
with stakeholders involving them closely
all of them and that means Farmers
Foresters Fishers Civil Society
scientists
let me also reassure you that the
commission will only assess member
states plans to see the EU Trends but it
will not approve or validate them
Mr Lisa you and some other member states
have expressed concern that the nature
restoration law would hamper hydropower
from Dam removals in rivers nowhere does
the nature restoration law proposal
require the establishment of hydropower
to the contrary it says literally
article 7.2 member states shall primary
address obsolete barriers which are
those that are no longer needed for
renewable energy generation or other
uses so we would
so we would expect member states to
Target primary obsolete barriers experts
estimated that at least 20 percent of
all barriers in the EU are obsolete so
they no longer serve any purpose
the number of hydropower plants in the
EU is estimated to be 23 000 which
represents barely two percent in the
total number of barriers it's therefore
be possible easily to respect the
proposed requirements without having
impact on hydroelectricity generation
and Mr Lisa you said we need to make
compromises to concile Nature protection
and economic activities or
infrastructure and you said you believe
in cooperation
I'm glad to hear this because I hope you
are ready to finalize this core decision
procedure in the same constructive
Spirit as we have started
one year ago or I would say four years
ago when the first time I've met you and
we had a discussion on this upcoming
mandate
and finally let me also use this
opportunity to clarify once for all that
the nature restoration law will not put
10 land out of production
first of all the 10 is not a mandatory
Target neither for individual member
states
especially not for a farm level hence
there is no obligation for individual
Farmers to take 10 of their land out of
production
it is mentioned as Benchmark referring
to the EU level objective set in the EU
biodiversity strategy for 2013. member
states are asked to increase the share
of agricultural land with high diversity
landscape features at National level
unit until a satisfactory level is
reached member states would Define
themselves in their National restoration
plans the satisfactory level they aim to
achieve and that level could be way
below 10 and as stressed in the
non-paper the commission is ready to
clarify objective of this provision and
adapt if it's necessary
dear colleagues
last but not least I remain optimistic
because
I know that since the beginning of this
mandate we have always worked
constructively
we have always shown that we can find
compromises and solutions we carve them
out in the most difficult legislations
and we have already reached agreements
on many important files sometimes very
difficult files and it would be
regretful and difficult to explain why
we didn't manage to do so also for one
of the most important pieces of the
legislation of the European green bill
honorable members let me be very clear
and honest a compromise is possible and
enriched the
divergencies are not as big as to
justify rejection other files have been
even more complicated and we managed
I sincerely hope we will not miss this
opportunity to bring nature restoration
law to a successful conclusion the
commission will play its role as honest
broker and do everything it can make to
make it happen
honorable members some of you voiced
concerns that this law May hamper our
economies putting Farmers Foresters
Fishers out of work let me be clear
there will be no work no income when
Nature is sick today we are proposing
the medicine the first to benefit from
this medicine will be the those whose
livelihoods directly depend on our
natural resources they need nature to be
healthy they need that for the
resilience and productivity of the land
of the Seas they needed to ensure food
security
some of you said that they are in favor
of nature restoration but they simply
asked for a new proposal from the
commission
let me be very clear we do have a
proposal
a proposal based on solid impact
assessment a proposal that has already
evolved on which we have presented a
known paper in June and on which member
states have already presented many
amendments touching among many issues
also raised in this house
a proposal
on which until April
all groups work constructively proposed
important amendments a proposal on which
even those groups who plead for
rejection have now tabled amendments for
the plenary world tomorrow honorable
members this is called core decision
let's finalize this process it is
possible and with a constructive
approach we could conclude it actually
quite quickly let's not miss this
opportunity we cannot lose time and we
don't need to lose time restoration is
our best hope of getting nature back in
shape we need that for climate
mitigation we need that for climate
adaptation we need that for our economy
the world is watching us our citizens
are watching
we set the pace at cop 15 in Montreal
and this is our chance to deliver at
home proving to the world that it can be
done proving to our citizens that we
keep our promises
last time
honorable members
let's secure a better future for our
citizens our Farmers our officials our
businesses our children thank you
challenge
thank you very much indeed Commissioners
and services and now may I call the
reporter to reply to the debate Mr Elena
thank you very much indeed president I
shall only give a few concluding remarks
I'd like to thank all those who've
contributed to the debate there were
many
many I think have defended the draft
legislation very well I'd like to thank
the commissioner exceptionally because
the commissioner and his whole team have
been very supportive obviously we've had
to contend with a lot of disinformation
the Fisheries committee did reject the
test the environment committee did not
I'd like to make that quite clear and
I'd like to thank all the Secretary of
envy and everybody else who contributed
in such a positive way to all the work
that's happened there but I have few
minutes remaining to me I'd simply like
to say we've listened to a lot of Upp
members some are still here some are not
who dislike this legislation we're in a
parliament here obviously we're going to
amend the legislation we're going to
correct it but we're not going to block
it because that is an anti-system
approach this is not something which
parliaments do simply decide to blockade
things no I don't think we have time for
a blue card Mr I don't wish to take one
to snap therefore we need to continue in
negotiation
that is what we The Way Forward
negotiation this is what I have been
saying for some time I stand here with
my hands held out to you asking the Epp
asking everybody to come to the
negotiating table to discuss it to
participate in try logs to participate
in discussion so that we can shape the
legislation together because in the end
of the date we negotiate we vote we have
to we will vote on the council's common
approach
and Ireland Greece Lithuania and Romania
have submitted amendments we will also
be voting on the amendment submitted
here in Parliament by the EPP
this is not a legislation a piece of
legislation against nature it's against
nobody it disadvantages nobody we in
this parliament are here to defend
nature and to defend Europe in the world
and this is one piece of that Mosaic and
I'm therefore optimistic and I hope that
some of the conservative the
conservatives will join with me in
supporting this legislation for nature
thank you much thank you very much
indeed to the reporter
this concludes that debate may I thank
all colleagues who participated
in what was a very rich debate which of
course is only right for such an
important piece of legislation as you
all know the vote will take place
tomorrow
we now move on to the next report which
is from Mr Nica and it's on the European
chips Act
may I therefore give the floor to the
erupter
thank you so much dear president
commissioner Breton it's a pleasure to
see you again
after long days of negotiations
on April 18 after a Swift